good evening and welcome to the planning
committee of stratford-on-avon District
Council my name's councilor Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this evening
um I'm going to start with some
housekeeping and just go through that we
are not expecting a fire alarm to my
knowledge so if it does go off please
evacuate the building and go to the car
park by the pub across the road and
we'll check your names off
the please make sure your phones are
turned off or at least since uh silent
mode just so they don't interrupt the
flow of the meeting I should remind you
all that this is a meeting in public
it's not a public meeting and so only
those who are registered to speak will
be able to do so at which point they
will be called forward and given further
instructions at that point the meeting
is being recorded and live streamed
um and I will now go on to introduce the
top table uh on my right we have Olivia
Quinn from democratic services and Kerry
Keller as well we have Sue Mullins who
is uh solicitor for this evening and to
my left I've got a planning manager Dale
Barker and planners Emma Booker Stuart
McIver
exec apologies
um
Dale I believe you got a statement you'd
like to read out thank you Joe yes my
role tonight is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you chair
thank you very much in which case we can
move on to the agenda um item one is
apologies for absence
thank you very much
and item two disclosures of interest
um I'll just start very quickly and say
that on item number three
I have a non-portunity interest in that
my wife is the Parish Clerk for napton
Parish Council
um oh I'm sorry it's the wrong
application number four
um
I come to this committee with an open
mind and no prior knowledge of the uh of
the application so I'll remain on the
committee for that one uh councilor
Pemberton thank you chair in relation to
app uh item three application 22 oblique
zero three three seven three
a bleak ful
um whilst not directly relating to this
particular application site uh the
previously allowed application on Appeal
on the same field in my role as Deputy
leader prior to the election I had
significant and substantial discussions
with officers residents and the parish
council whilst I do believe I could come
to the matter with an open mind frankly
I don't think it would pass the sniff
test in terms of perception and
therefore I will be stepping away and
will take no part in that this
particular item
thank you very much any more
Declarations of Interest
no in which case we'll move on to our
first item which is application 22
03373 ful Lander joining Greenways
Arden's Grafton Road Temple Grafton uh
Emma Booker is our presenting officer
when you're ready take it away
thank you chair
so before members tonight I've got an
application for a development that would
change the use of paddock Land to
provide a site for a single Gypsy and
traveler pitch
a new vehicle access is proposed which
would connect the site to Arden Grafton
Road alongside hard standing where a day
room touring Caravan static caravan and
space for off street parking and secure
bin storage will be provided you can see
on the map in front of you that the
application site is where the that black
dot is located
location plan for you here um the
application site is edged in red
we are in an open Countryside location
and the site is between the two Villages
of Temple Grafton and Arden's Grafton
we're in a special landscape area
specifically the Arden landscape and we
consider that this application site
contributes to the setting of two
conservation areas of which you can see
the temple Grafton one edged in pink and
then the Arden Grafton one is just
visible on the bottom left-hand side of
that map
please also be aware of the public
rights of way which run to the north and
to the west of the application site
aerial photo showing the application
site in its rural context you can see
that it is surrounded by agricultural
land
this photo is slightly out of date
however as The Birches application site
of the adjacent Gypsy pitch is not shown
on that photo
I've put this one in to show where the
The Birches the adjacent single Gypsy
pictures shown that's with the orange
box and the application site in red and
also shown where that public footpath to
the north of the of the application site
runs
um please note that the land topography
slopes downwards from that public
footpath towards the Arden Grafton Road
so my site photos now these were taken
very recently
um the star shows where I'm standing at
this point
so you can see that views from this
public right-of-way are they completely
screen the application site I was not
able to see where the development be
cited from here
I've moved further up the public
right-of-way now so this photo just
shows the relationship that the
application site would have with those
dwellings on Croft Lane
and I consider that the views from these
two-story properties on on uh Croft Lane
would be would be limited
due to their hedging screening that's
provided
so this photo's taken from the other
public right-of-way which runs north to
south to the west of the site
the application site would sit behind
that hedge where the red box is shown
this hedge is proposed to be retained
and I consider that it offers
significant screening and the site would
not be visible from this vantage point
proposed site plan here
and you can see the relationship that
the proposed development would have with
that adjacent Gypsy pitch you can also
see the proposed development and its
layout with the permanent day room the
two Caravans and the off street parking
bin storage as well
so this is my photo taken on the Arden
graftons Road this is where the access
is to be
punched through the Hedgerow
um I can confirm that no trees are going
to be fouled but
the juvenile Hedgerow would be would be
removed
Street Scene looking down towards Arden
grafton's Village now I put this one in
to Show members that you know there is
mature vegetation planted on either side
of the road and it will offer some some
screening to the development
is the day room which would be the
permanent building on the site
and this is the application site itself
so you can see the hedro which I would
consider to provide effective screening
when observed from that public
right-of-way on the west hand side
and I've recommended to members that
this application be granted despite the
harm identified to the landscape and the
special landscape area
the fact that it's that there is a
significant lack of available sites for
the Gypsy and travel Community has been
afforded significant weight in the
planning balance
and I we as officers consider that the
public benefit derived from the
provision of a pitch has significant
benefits and would outweigh the harm
identified to the landscape
um we considered that the harm yeah is
outweighed sorry
um please refer to your update sheets
um I since writing the report received
um comment from the County Council and
their Gypsy traveler team
they confirmed that there is a shortage
of sites
um
they they said there's a chance that
this applicant has approached them
um and they said that from what they
know of the family they consider them to
meet the definition of gypsy and
traveler set out in National policy
and that's all I have to say
um yeah so yeah we're recommending
approval thank you
thank you very much in which case we can
now move to our first Speaker who is
councilor Robert Kemp from Temple
Grafton Parish Council
counselor Kemp if you like to come
forward
if any of those seats up there I'll be
up soon any of those seats there is fine
you have three minutes if you can press
the button to turn the red light on to
make sure the microphone's on
um I'll give you a 30 second warning and
otherwise you can take it away
first one
thank you very much
the main issues are the effects of The
Proposal the character and appearance of
the area including the Arden special
landscape
and that the effect is unacceptably
harmful and whether any other
consideration outweigh that harm
these are not my words but the statement
made by Andrew Owen the inspector
appointed by the Secretary of State to
view this site on appeal
the inspector stated that Greenway
signifies the western boundary of Temple
Grafton
and the next settlement to the West is
Arden's Grafton
they are twin Villages known
historically as the graftons
the openness of the fields and their
function which separate the graftons as
part of the undeveloped Gap
and contribute strongly to the character
of the area
Mr Andrew Owen the planning inspector
stated categorically
when one field remains
unopened sorry I've missed I missed I
apologize to this
I had to make some adjustments
I'm just saying I've just Paul's whilst
you're just getting your papers I
apologize a conservation review in 1997
stated that the gap between the graftons
should remain undeveloped
the two settlements though twinned are
very different in architecture period
and Design
and infill the gap between the graftons
would greatly diminish the impact of
their diverse charm
granting planning permission for a
traveler's site I am sure is not a box
taking exercise but a very sympathetic
process to achieve Harmony integration
and most of all to build a mutual
respect in the community
Mr Andrew Owen said he would not support
any development between the graftons
if there were Travelers pitches
available elsewhere
seven pitches have been granted planning
permission in Croft Lane Temple Grafton
along with the five pitches already
occupied
the development of the seven pitches has
not yet commenced so one might question
the urgency of a housing need
it is also worthy of note 30 seconds
so I'm sorry it is also worthy of note
that these are huge
differences between a housing need and a
Mr Andrew in the planning inspector
stated categorically when one field
gains planning permission the adjourning
Fields will follow and this moment in
time there is a further planning
applications for three more pitches on
the same site if a settlement of this
size were to happen the twinning of the
graftons would disappear and the unique
status of two villages in one if you
could just wrap up on that one okay
thank you thank you very much councilor
um would you like to turn this off now
uh yes you can just turn that one off
lovely thank you but just stay there for
a second
um members do we have any questions for
our Parish counselor
no nothing in that case thank you very
much feel free to go thank you
all right
um we have
a ward member now registered to speak
who's counselor Stanley
hello counselor Stanley um you have five
minutes
um same procedure so if you just press
the button to start and I'll give you a
30 second warning and uh take it away
when you're ready thank you chair
members you have heard representation on
behalf of the parish council who oppose
this application I also object to the
application and set up the planning
grounds and the approach you as decision
makers can take even noting what the
officer's view that the planning balance
is tilted because of the acknowledged
deficit and provision of gypsy and
traveler sites there is much to get
through in five minutes so we'll start
with the grounds for refusal number one
being the development will have a
significant and undeniably adverse
impact on and create harm to the
character and setting of Temple Grafton
and Arden's Grafton specifically the
coalescence between the two settlements
envisaged by Arden grafton's
Conservation Area review and policy CS
15. number two being the application
will significantly and demonstrably
reduce the site's function as part of
the undeveloped gap between the two
settlements which contribute contribute
strongly to the character of the area
this is not in accordance with polyester
policy CS5 and cs15 and the significant
harm caused outweighs the public benefit
of the development
the application site sits in isolation
between each settlement which bisects
the Gap in such a way that it weakens
its impact by diminishing its value and
size splitting it into two and so that
is contrary to policy cs15 that was
point three point four being the loss of
the Hedgerow notably diminishes its
functioning it's its function in
creating the sense of the Gap its
character and the harm Creator cannot be
reclaimed by planting a similar a
similar length of Hedgerow elsewhere
five is that the development management
consideration to a policy cs15
identifies the adverse cumulative impact
that individual proposals can have to
create a general decline in the quality
of the landscape this application would
have such a declining effect and the
adverse impact is not outweighed by the
public benefits of the application
the officer's report references the
appeal decision for development in the
same field immediately adjacent to
Greenways that planning appeal decision
neatly rehearses the considerations for
decision makers to consider in this
application also the officer says tilted
balance applies in that the acknowledged
harm of The Proposal is outweighed by
the benefits provision of additional
pictures I disagree with that assessment
and invite you to take the opposite View
and to come to a different view on the
planning balance
there is no doubt that it refusal to
sorry there is no doubt that a refusal
to Grant permission will be appealed
however carefully worded reason for
refusal would protect in so far as
possible The Authority from a Costas
award the officer considers two key
issues as did the appeal inspector
number one being the impact of the site
on the coalescence between Temple
Grafton and Arden's Grafton and number
two our core strategy policies
the key planning reason to refusal of
this application is the impact on the
character and appearance of the co of
the coalescence between Temple graft and
nardis Grafton of this specific
application and the cumulative impact on
the gap between the two settlements I
would specifically refer members to
consider paragraphs four to six of the
appeal decision
this application will have a
significantly greater impact on the Gap
as it is further away from the Greenways
to The Observer it would be seen as a
development in the middle of the Gap so
clearly and significantly impacting on
the coalescence to such a degree that
the Tilted balance argument no longer
applies a risk of the appeal inspector
highlighted
furthermore the addition additional loss
of Hedgerow will significantly undermine
the impact on the gap between the
settlements
the fact that an equivalent length of
Hedgerow will be provided completely
misses the point and the purpose of the
Hedgerow a factor will see highlighted
by the inspector in paragraph 9 of his
decision notice
fundamentally the adverse impact of this
development is not outweighed by the
public benefit of the additional Gypsy
and traveler provision the officer
recognizes that the application is not
in Conformity with the following
policies as decision makers you can
rightly take a different view on the
weight attached to these policies and
the officer
in this case cs15 identifies the Arden
special landscape area and and in
addition members should also take into
account the development management
considerations 0.2 page 78 of the core
strategy which states
some proposals may seem innocuous but
cumulatively could form part of a
general decline in the quality of the
landscape it is my opinion that this
development falls into that category
fairly and squarely
this application is not in accordance
with as-10 policy specifically paragraph
7.
cs21 the application is not in
accordance with paragraph two and
importantly paragraph 7 the site cannot
realistically access facilities and also
buy anything covered in a car as the a46
is between the application site and
Ulster
Temple Grafton primary school has been
unable to accommodate Duty and traveler
children from other local sites and
cannot do so for the occupiers of this
site the applicant has also failed to
address paragraph 12 of cs21 and there
is no evidence brought by the officer
that this issue can be addressed by
condition
so in conclusion members you should give
more weight to the impact on coalescence
30 seconds given sorry you should give
more in more weight to the impact on
coalescence than given by the officer
and take the view that this overcomes
the Tilted balance argument thank you
thank you very much councilor Stanley uh
well within your time members do we have
any questions for our Ward member
councilor Harvey
not not mean to catch you out that's not
my intention at all but you said
something there which I don't think is
reflected in the officer's report and
that was you made a reference to the
lack of school places is there something
more you can tell us about that
well so as as we know in within within
the county the school places are this
guys anyway we always talk about
infrastructure and I they they've been
unable to um
to provide places for existing sites
um we're in within Temple London's
Grafton so they won't be able to uh
afford closes for this site
castle of Fleming
just to reinforce something you say
about no spaces at Temple Grafton School
the nearest school after that is bidford
and bidford's full yeah so there's no
spaces at bidford Castle famine can we
just keep it to questions please okay
sorry so
um having found that there's no spaces
in Temple Grafton have you been able to
find where there's any other
opportunities for children to go to
I guess even you would look at Ulster
and again that's not accessible by
anything other than card because of the
a46 being in between the application
site and Ulster itself
any other questions for award member
in that case thank you very much and
you're free to go thank you
all right so we're now moving on to
points of clarification from our offices
um I'm going to start with
um
one which was um
there was an appeal that was referenced
by the parish council
um with regards to the land between the
two Villages
um could you just clarify how um that's
been considered
in terms of the um the language
expressing the the desire to maintain
the gap between the two Villages I'm not
sure if it was the the appeal that's
referenced in the reporter or another
one
sorry chair we're struggling a little
bit could we could we ask you to restate
the question for us I do apologize we're
we're not clear what we're being asked
to answer that's absolutely fine um the
Parish Council made reference to an
appeal decision I believe that
referenced specifically the land in
between the two villages in which this
development is being proposed indicating
that it should remain undeveloped can
you confirm if that is from the appeal
decision that you've referenced in the
report or another one and if it is from
another one has that been taken into
account
yes so there's an appeal decision for
the adjacent site which is named The
Birches
um in that appeal decision the inspector
made a very detailed assessment of the
landscape impact and recognized that
this gap between the two Villages is a
significant feature of the landscape
area of Arden because it creates this
gap between the two villages
small nuclear Villages are a character
of the landscape so he thought it's a
significant feature which should be
protected
in my assessment I've acknowledged that
yes this would lead to a development
to the development of an open field
which obviously is the gap
recognized that it will lead to the
erosion of the significance of the wider
Gap because we're in filling a site
within it
um so I'm not the officers have
recognized that there is landscape harm
and we have had regard for the appeal
decision we've come to a similar view
but obviously this application before us
is an additional development in that Gap
so members have to have consider whether
you know the landscape harm that results
from this one in conjunction with the
other is unacceptable and a reason for
refusal
But to answer the Chairman's question
correctly sorry it's the same appeal
decision that we've already referred yes
it's the same one yeah thank you thank
you very much I believe uh Council
Harvey next
thank you chairman
I'm concerned in my own to get straight
in my own mind
the degree to which it is a material
consideration
um to try and assess the cumulative
impact of
um traveler sites in a particular
confined location in one Village as I
understand it this would be the third
application the third application site
in Temple Grafton and the point has been
made by the councilor from the parish
council I think
that there are seven pictures which have
been agreed which have not yet been
occupied
I'm also conscious that this site
is separated from the single site
I think the purchase and there is a gap
between
and I I presume we are not entitled to
speculate about what might happen to
that land in between but my I'd like
some clarification if you can provide it
on the degree to which we are entitled
to take into account
the cumulative effect set against the
shortfall of gypsy and traveler places
generally within the district
I hope that's clear enough
if you're just by with me I'm going to
go to the government guidance and just
find the exact relevant bits
it would this job would be really easy
if we could just choose once one
paragraph from some government advice
and that would decide the application
um
to answer your question directly
councilor paragraph 25 of the planning
policy for travelers sites says local
planning authorities should ensure that
sites in rural areas respect the
scale-off and do not dominate the
nearest settled community and avoid
placing an undue pressure on the local
infrastructure
but that of course has to be balanced
against the need for accommodation and
that's where the the difficult balancing
comes in
currently officers are concluding that
this site
excuse me I'm losing the voice does not
dominate the nearest settled Community
clearly there will be a Tipping Point
and I'm not going to speculate what that
might be
councilor parinex
thank you
um chairman I was actually going to ask
a very similar question to councilor
Harvey
plus I was also Keen to know the
distance
um to the nearest residential dwelling
from this site and also The Birches site
approximate
house next door to Birches yeah so you
can see on the slide before us the
nearest neighbor is called Greenways and
that is to the east
and it's about
100 to 150 meters away
obviously this Birches which is an
existing Gypsy and traveler pitch is
directly adjacent to that neighbor
if the distance is critical counselor we
can measure it okay it's fine
counselor Keith here next
yeah thanks chair
um I just wanted to pick up on a couple
of things I've got a couple of questions
I'm going to refer back to what I've
just heard about respecting the scale
and
uh a development not dominating the
landscape so that's sort of the context
um when the case officer was speaking
she explained that the views from Croft
Lane properties were limited
and you also explained and showed us
photographs of the visibility of the
site both from the road and also from
the track and I would add that I have
seen the site from Public Access places
the track is a right-of-way
um and also the road obviously
so
um I'm interested really to know just
how visible that site is from the Croft
presumably upstairs in the properties on
the Croft and from public access points
I'm interested in in your view of that
because the view that I formed as I
walked around was it was really quite
difficult to see into the site
so um my photos that I showed to members
tonight they were taken a couple of days
ago and I could not see the application
site from the public rights of way
um from Croft Lane that's a ribbon form
of development up to the yeah north of
the village
you could see from within the
application site some of the first floor
windows but these were properties right
up the North End of Croft Lane so that's
when I say that views are limited
because they are
and we're talking a distance for maybe
half a kilometer away so
you could just follow up on that then so
as you walk on the track you can see
roofs of properties all over
between the two Villages so that you
know the views from the public footpath
show that
um what I wanted to ask next is is I
noticed when I was going up the path
that the view Into The Birches was a
very direct view
um probably unlike many of the houses
actually that as you're going along the
road you look straight into The Birches
and it struck me that when I looked at
The Birches
permission the the location of of the
development wasn't exactly what was
shown to me when I looked at the
um the details of the site that were in
the original application that was
granted on appeal the question then is
is is there a way of because
protecting the the feeling of the
separation of the villagers and
preventing a feeling of coalescence is
there a way of of conditioning the
entrance to the site such that the um
developments are not are screened from
view from the road and not immediately
open to view as in the case of The
Birches
so in the recommended conditions we
would condition a landscape plan this is
the proposed site plan here
the landscape plan would need to Accord
with that layout so yes we can secure
some planting that would screen but I'm
not going to say that we can like
completely screen
the views into the site from the access
because that's the proposed arrangement
and the narrow width of the site doesn't
give the applicant much
freedom to kind of change the layout
what was in my mind in asking that
question is in some past experience of
mine
into large larger sites admittedly there
was a dog leg entrance which meant that
when you were on the road you couldn't
actually see into the site at all
thank you counselor Keithley councilor
Curtis next please
a couple of
points of clarification if I could
um
I'm just wondering we've been told that
there is a shortfall in provision for
traveler sites
but at the same time we've also been
told that there are spaces available on
the Croft Lane site
so I'm wondering if you can give some
guidance as to how we balance the weight
given to those two areas and my other
question was
um I'm not trying to catch you out here
and you referred to the day room as a
permanent room in your presentation
but your recommendation is that it's
probably grant for four years I'm
wondering how we reconcile those two so
I didn't mean to catch you on that one
thank you
um so in response to your first question
the approval for the pictures on the
Cross Lane
uh
development
members attached a condition to that or
the council attached to the condition
that restricts occupation of those
vacant pictures to family members only
of the applicant
so yes there may be vacant plots but
this applicant for the current proposal
would not be able to access those plots
because they don't comply with the
condition
um
what was the second one
second one you made reference oh yes
permanent building
um
ignore that I didn't say that yeah we
have um in theory it needs to be
removable from the site so
it's not a caravan basically that's what
I was trying to say
castle of Fleming next to play
it just might take me a second to get to
the question
um
uh planning manager has been talking a
lot here about balance and the question
I'm asking really is the balance or the
weight sorry the weight that you've put
onto the requirement for Egyptian
traveler pitches
does that outweigh the harm to the odd
and Landscape
um I mean it's something we have to
decide whether because if this is a
green belt it might be a different story
but what I'm saying is is the Arden
landscape of less value than the green
belt so that you know we can appreciate
whether you the fact that you've put
weight onto the requirement for Egyptian
traveler pitches whereas we might want
to put weight on the fact that it's the
Arden landscape in the same way that we
would do with a green belt that's that's
all I'm asking so are you saying that
that that weight that you're putting on
the Gypsy and traveler requirement
outweighs the Arden landscape that's the
question
I think the answer to that question
Germany's yes
okay
um I've come to
um councilor passing him next but I just
wanted to ask a quick one myself
actually
um School places was referenced I
Believe by our board member and that was
something I was asked uh particularly in
reference to the number of school places
that there were in close proximity
um especially
um I haven't been able to find anything
within the report which suggests we have
an indication of those are you able to
elaborate on what availability there
might be considering that's a material
aspect that you have mentioned in terms
of
supporting it
chairman there's we have limited
information on school places available
to us to to answer your question
um what I do understand is that the the
children involved with this family are
currently in school
um which is always a good sign with with
traveler families and they're in school
in bidford
so they are in a local school although
not the local school
I hope that answers your question
councilor passing him next
um
is is there any precedent or are there
many presidents for uh sites to be
between Villages I I'm in my experience
is that they're always outside Villages
and they're between Villages so
um could you is that Norm are they
normally in situations like this or
um is is particularly different from
other sites that are between villages
I think that's another question that
qualifies for my answer yes chairman
most of them are between Villages yeah
thank you councilor homes next
so
seeing what sort of impact this
additional site would have on reducing
across the district the the demand
foreign
Gypsy and traveler accommodation
assessment that was updated in 2019
um that was something that the council
commissioned
from that they identified a need across
the district for 59 pitches for Gypsies
and travelers that meet the definition
adopted by planning policy so
there's a neat there is a there is a
significant need obviously this
development would only contribute one to
that need but we've given that weight in
the planning balance
Pastor Keithley only a point of
clarification on that last answer please
the 59 is over an extended period but
there was a separate if I'm right wasn't
there a separate Target or a separate
shortfall for a shorter period
up I think to 2024
when I consult with policy on that they
didn't advise me of that so I'm not
aware of a different different period it
might be that you're referring to the
2016 assessment this was updated so with
the time scales have changed
okay thanks I'm not sure to be honest I
thought when I read the I read the um
ppts report and I thought it was 2019
and I was under the impression that I
read that there was a target a smaller
Target for the first few years following
the the day of the GTAA
that's all thank you
yeah just just to wrap that up chair uh
I thought I I can't this evening give
you a figure for
this year a target for this year for a
number of of pictures the target is to
deliver 59 pictures over the period 2019
to 2035.
so we're in 2023 now which is four years
into that period and our progress
against 59 it isn't
On Target
to deliver 59 in that period
councilor Harvey could I just follow up
on an appointed councilor pasigan made
um in relation to normally uh pictures
are to be found between Villages could
you confirm that the second largest site
in the district I.E the darling's got
Crossroads site has ended up there not
because the council chose to put it
there or to approve a plan there but
because it was occupied in the first
place and uh and it was taken out of the
hands of the council in effect that that
was an application that was opposed so
these these settlements of Travelers
sites are not always as a result of an
overt planning application in the
traditional way could you confirm that
please
uh I I think what I can confirm chair is
that quite often the location of gypsy
sites are chosen by gypsies I'm not
aware of the history that councilor
Harvey was referring to so I can't
confirm that but it wouldn't surprise me
in the slightest if that was how it was
delivered because it is quite common
councilor Henderson thank you chair can
um you're giving some detail on this day
room Construction
is it solid construction brick
while Emma's looking for that chairman
um
I think it would probably be helpful for
members to know that the site on Croft
Lane when it was originally granted
permission was for a four-year temporary
period uh and it was also envisaged that
each of the pitchers on that Croft Lane
site would have a brick built day room
by the inspector
when he granted that four-year temporary
permission so we are following that
pattern set by that inspector on the
Croft Lane site some 13 14 years ago
any more uh Catholic Keithley quickly if
possible yeah just quickly but I'm I'm
still concerned about the um
the visual appearance of the entrances
could I ask the case officer whether or
not
she feels it would be possible to
condition a landscaping design such that
it would not be possible to see straight
in to all the paraphernalia of the site
as in the case of The Birches
um in it for this particular application
foreign this is the plan that they've
proposed I can't we can't alter it by
condition so if this is the layout which
is approved then then this is the I
can't change it by condition so
the Landscaping scheme would need to add
an extra layer to that layout
so yeah
I think it's perhaps it's worth adding
chair that although on the surface of it
it would be desirable and
straightforward to design an access that
came in at an oblique angle so that you
could plant in front of it so there was
no direct view of the site
um
the other side of the coin and I've
never towed a caravan is that they have
much less maneuverability than my car
does and I really don't know whether it
would be possible to maneuver a caravan
in along the route that you're
suggesting but I understand why you're
asking the question
are there any more points of
clarification I think we've been fairly
exhaustive in which case we can move to
debate who would like to start councilor
Parry
um
I think this is a very very challenging
application before us
the one issue the biggest issue for me
the really biggest issue for me
is the gap between the two Villages once
it's gone it's gone
and I think I would have
far less
concern
if the application site was adjacent to
immediately adjacent to The Birches
because we would still then retain this
Gap
so
I am going to put a lot of weight
because this Gap gets removed
and the graftons
have a phenomenal Heritage and history
and we need to do everything to protect
the boundaries of the two Villages and
the Gap in terms of how the villages
were conceived
um
so I am going to propose refusal on the
grounds
of the impact on the Arden landscape the
removal of the gap
because
as I say I think if this application had
been immediately adjacent to The Birches
I will be saying Grant because I
wouldn't see but where the site where
the actual site is it just goes Plum
Center into the Gap and I think we
should be protecting
our special character and landscape
and I acknowledge that we have a
shortfall
but one pitch against 59 isn't going to
make an indent at all and I and I just
think we should be putting our weight
Behind The Villages I'm also
particularly concerned
you needed a cohesive community and I
think if this site was developed
that it just
destroys the connectivity or the the Gap
connectivity between the two Villages so
I rest my case
thank you councilor Parry uh cuddler
Curtis next I believe
thank you I have some very broadly in
agreement with what council Perez just
said and I think also we
I accept this is a gypsum traveler site
that we're looking at in this
application
but very recently before this committee
we had an application for a dwelling a
conventional dwelling in a very similar
situation between two settlements and it
was refused partly on the basis that it
lay outside the built of area boundary
of both and it was similar to this so I
think
notwithstanding the need to provide
Travelers sites
um I think we do need some sort of
consistency in approach to this and yes
I I have the same concerns expressed by
by councilor Perry I think they're
contrary to this would be contrary to a
number of the um points in in cs21 thank
you
castle hobby next
I think this has been a very difficult
finely balanced application to to
consider I can well understand why the
officer has
weighed up the the elements and come to
her recommendation
listening to the discussion the
information that was presented
um it's a Pity that we didn't have firm
information about education and
infrastructure type of type of arguments
we've had to rely upon
anecdotal evidence rather than hard
facts but put that on one side
the thing I share the concern about the
lack of the Gap and I take councilor
Perry's argument about the the adjacent
uh an application had it been adjacent
to the existing pitch
um
I am I think the most telling single
element to me was the reference by the
inspector in the appeal to the his
argument his appreciation his
understanding that the gap between the
two Villages should be maintained we've
had the ward member we've had the parish
council make similar arguments
on balance I'm inclined to support a
refusal rather than a grand
thank you very much I believe councilor
Curtis wanted to go next
thank you just to follow up
um
I think
it's not for this committee tonight but
I think that providing this one traveler
site doesn't really address the key
issue but it does highlight the fact
that we do need to address that more
broadly that's all I wanted to add chair
thank you thank you councilor passing
him well I'm in favor of the application
because it's always going to be
difficult to find traveler sites there's
always going to be objections this is
just
one one small site and I don't think
their harm is very great in that it's
not very visible from The Villages and
it's not very obtrusive for the rights
of way so I I think the the benefits
outweigh the Harms
yeah thank you councilor Fleming
yeah just going back to my balance
question when I was talking about how we
put weight on
the uh the harm to the landscape and
and the the requirement for extra Gypsy
pictures my balance is the opposite way
to the officers recommendation so from
my perspective
um I'll be supporting the refusal
is that a second
we're not had a formal second yet so
Keithley
yeah thanks chair
um yeah I'd agree very very difficult
term application to consider and I think
at the root of it is this failure to
provide sites elsewhere as identified in
a report back in 2019
made very difficult by the inspectors
findings on the um the purchase however
um I am leaning towards agreeing to
councilor Parry that the gap between the
graftons at this point is is what we
should focus on and I think that the The
Birches
um was adjacent to one of the
settlements so I think that the there is
an argument that the previous
application didn't have the same impact
on the gap between the settlements as
this as this one does
so the way I'm leaning at the moment is
is towards um agreeing with councilor
parry and refusing
thank you very much I'm inclined to
agree I'm sorry I'll come to a council
enter serif in next but I'll just add in
um I do I do generally agree actually
with the majority of the speakers so far
in that actually that's the landscape
significance and the to my mind impact
that that has on the historic
environment as well particularly given
this setting directly in the middle of
two conservation areas I think to my
mind that's the most critical aspect
which does hold significant weight
considering that the uh the principle of
this application is on planning balance
I'll go to Cal Sledge seraphin next
thank you chair yeah Simon Klein to
agree
um this being isolated between the two
villages
um
it's
in my mind if this is past then
they'll be springing up everywhere I
know I realized we need traveler sites
but they have to be in the appropriate
place so I will be going against the
officer's recommendation
okay thank you very much because I had
seraphin uh does anyone else want to
speak on this one we've been fairly
exhausted in our uh points of
clarification and I'm glad to hear a
third of eight
um
Dale do we have everything you need
help with the reason for
free I'm looking for a little bit of
help with the the reason for refusal
chair um specifically can you take me
back to the the relevant policy of the
District of the core strategy
um somebody mentioned cs21 which of
course is a gypsy traveler policy I'm
not sure that that directly picks up on
the concerns that were were articulated
which seemed to be more landscape
related which is cs-12
um but
guide me a little bit please and we'll
we'll work up with whatever you give me
all right
I I still feel that point 12 because uh
there won't be the community cohesion
between the settled and the traveler
communities because it's right bang in
the middle of the gap
so of cs21
the most important thing is the area the
the the impact on the Arden landscape
area and also as the chair highlighted
encapsulating what I was talking about
the historical connections it's the
Herod it's not just the Gap it's the gap
between two significant conservation
areas of two villages
so that's really the focus but I do
still also feel as part of cs21
and yeah the the point too the site is
not is not located well no it is it is
located in uh it shouldn't be
sorry I think there's enough there if we
if we can pick up on on CS 21 paragraph
12 and um Emma will address that and
then we'll we'll move on from there if
that's okay
when I read uh Point 12 of policy 20
cs21
I feel that that is to do with the
appearance of the site rather than
okay
sauce
sorry chair I do feel it it is sitting
in a designated between two designated
historic Villages yeah so so yeah that
would be the landscape harm but if
you're looking to refuse it based on the
fact that it's not they're not going to
be cohesive within the community it's
finding a policy to back that point up
which I don't think number 12 is
relevant to
to my mind that's
um covered more by uh CS5 being
landscape and then 12 as well uh being
special landscape areas those are the
ones that I I identified myself yeah and
I mean I also you if we wanted to be
more comprehensive maybe look at cs8 as
well but I'm I'm no okay
if we're happy with that
okay uh in that case we have a proposal
to refuse the application uh proposed by
councilor Parry seconded by councilor
Fleming
and
that's
and the wording of that is to be agreed
with the officers
um in relation to the landscape
um criteria okay uh in that case can I
see all those in favor of refusal
all those opposed
in that case uh
application 22
03373 ful is refused
okay thank you very much everyone
uh we'll now move on to item number four
uh which is application
2300332 slash very land off Jackson Lane
napton on the hill
uh presenting officer is Stuart McIver
and I'll give him some time to sit down
and then we can uh take it away
thank you chair good evening everyone
so sorry I'm just uh waiting for
councilor Pemberton to rejoin committee
at which point we can commence thank you
in which case you can uh you can take it
away thanks
thank you chair
so the proposal before members is
variation of condition three of a 2018
outline application which was originally
refused by the council but allowed an
appeal with all matters reserved for the
erection of two dwellings
at land off Jackson Lane Latin on the
hill which you can see the application
site is denoted by the black dot on the
screen
so the map illustrates the application
site which is outlined in red again as
you can see on the screen here
it's to the southern outskirts of napton
on the hill
so here we have the permitted site
location plan with the 28 that was
permitted with the 2018 application
outline application
again you can see the out application
site outlined in red leading off Jackson
Lane
so in summary it is considered that the
proposal to vary the wording of
condition three to read as the
development hereby permitted must be
begun not later than the expiration of
two years from the date of approval of
the last of the reserve matters to be
approved will make the condition precise
as per the requirements of paragraph 56
of the mppf and bring it in line with
Section 92 of the Town and Country
planning act it is therefore recommended
that the application is granted
permission thank you chair
thank you very much Stuart uh we only
have one registered speaker who is our
award member counselor Rock
Castle Rock you've got five minutes
um I'll give you a 30 second warning
uh
otherwise you can take it away when
you're ready
thank you very much chairman and good
evening colleagues
uh I've prepared three pictures
um just for context
this site is accessed by means of a
private road not in the applicant's
ownership and the spot is something of a
nature Haven it is low-lying marshy
ground that acts as an attenuation Pond
for the stream that runs through it
although even so there is a history of
flooding Downstream
this does not appear to be evidence
placed before the inspector
it is further debatable if the appeal
will be successful now because the
council has adopted since then a climate
emergency stance and the map to enabled
development plan has been made which has
policies resisting the loss of trees and
biodiversity habitats
in my view these matters would weigh
against a fresh similar application and
to that extent I disagree with the
officer's report
however whilst his background would be
relevant should the permission expire
that is not the issue before you now
it is the nature of the time limits that
have previously been set to develop the
site
on the previous application spent quite
a bit of time discussing and referencing
previous planning inspectors views
this application seeks to change the
word in the inspector applied namely
that it should take place within two
years of the reserve matters and replace
that wording with commencement within
two years
it is unusual that this or any planning
Authority would seek to modify
considered terms at a planning inspector
had applied
without good reason to do so
we usually regard the planning
inspectors decisions are somewhat
sacrosanct
and indeed we use such decisions as
future guidance and precedent which is
what you've been doing over the past few
minutes
in this case the inspector says in
paragraph 20 of the appeal decision and
I quote I have considered the council's
suggested conditions and amended the
wording
the application seeks to directly
overturn this
furthermore the inspector specifically
said conditions including that related
to commencement of development are
necessary
now due to a misunderstanding the parish
council chairman unfortunately admitted
to register to speak before the deadline
yesterday is actually sitting behind me
and uh he fully supports what I'm saying
uh
the parish council have asked me to
point out their comments summarized on
page 27 in the report I.E that there is
no evidence that the wording by the
inspector was an error
in fact the country is the case as the
inspector specifically says he took the
council's recommendations into account
shall take place and commencement on I'm
not a rtpi planner but I think I can
read English it means something slightly
different to me in fact substantially
different
making a commencement can be as little
as laying a water supply or a power
supply to a site
whether you think that means of
development has taken place isn't much
of you to judge
I would think there are of significant
difference
I contend that no changes to the
planning inspectors wording uh on this
application should be made and the
application should be refused thank you
chairman
thank you councilor rock well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our Ward member
no nothing's forthcoming in which case
thank you very much for your
contribution
all right we've no other registered
speakers so we'll move on to points of
clarification from our officer members
do we have any points of clarification
Pemberton
thank you chair um
I note the reference to
um
section 92 of the Town and Country
planning act but
um
can the officer confirm that that must
be begun wording is used in every single
outline planning permission granted by
this Authority
sorry councilor I haven't read them all
I believe so
you both
Castle Keithley thanks uh thanks chair
um as as I see this and I I read the
report the issue is that that the
wording that was used by the inspector
shall take place is imprecise
because you can read it in more than one
way
so my question to the case officer is um
this application
was refused and appealed
which way do you think the inspector
would read shall take place
I think at appeal German an inspector
would consider the reasons for and
against changing this wording and I
think he would consider that there isn't
a cigarette papers width difference
between the wording of the two and I
think he would probably allow the appeal
but
I haven't seen the evidence that the
inspector would see that's the reasoning
that led us to the recommendation that
we've made
Mr Harvey
I'm normally I'm normally known as a
patent but I'm I'm somewhat
um the arguments here are quite finesse
as as I as I read them can I just be
clear in my understanding that if this
deficitor's recommendation were not
followed and it was to be refused would
the effect of such a decision be
effectively to with have the effect of
withdrawing planning consent because of
lack of time
um no chairman the the effect of either
wording would be the same that the um
development must start not later than
two years from the date of approval
other last the reserve matters and I'm
sorry I am going to have a look at
Stewart here and ask have the reserve
mat has been approved they have haven't
they yeah that's why it's extent yeah so
the reserve matters have been approved
and they expire in November
November 2023 yeah so they can commence
development under either of those
wordings by November
thank you
Council Pemberton
not as far as I'm aware of no basis
there's nothing to stop uh commencement
to the Planet of the development
tomorrow
no
but the application seeks in essence a
further two years
so what does it actually what is it
actually seeking
German there will be
unless someone cleverer than me can can
find a distinction between them there is
no difference between those two wordings
they will still have to start work on
the same day or by the same day which is
November this year
there is no no extension of time in fact
under Section
um under this type of application you
may not extend the start date for
development it's the only thing that you
can't do
is extend the start date so this is not
extending the start date
Castle Parry as
you have to forgive me that I'm perhaps
getting a little bit
um old in my years so
I'm just trying to get my head around us
why they've then come forward to change
the wording is it is it because perhaps
they they may seek to put in a a
different scheme if if a different app
if it if an amended version of The
Reserve matters comes forward between
now
and November would there be any impact
on the changing of these words
another of my one word answers no
any more questions clarification
in which case we're moving on to our
debate uh councilor Harvey raring to go
I can think of no material planning
reason
to contradict the recommendation that's
been made by the planning officer so I
shall I'm quite happy to propose Grant
thank you councilman Harvey I'm going to
jump in and second that because
um
I think reading the report this is a
regular regularization of
of the language that was used within the
inspectors report I don't see that it
there is any cause to reopen the
application on March
um and I'm broadly satisfied that this
won't actually impact on the
implementation of the uh the the
application
um in and of itself so I'm happy to say
that would anyone like else like to
speak on the item
doesn't it picked so so in that case
um we are voting to approve the
application in front of us in line with
the officers recommendations
can I see all those in favor
thank you very much in that case uh
committee resolves to Grant application
2300332 slash very
thank you very much
okay we're now moving on to our final
application item number five which is
application
22-03671 ful
um which is for numbers 3 15 22 and 23
Bennett Place illmington
uh
presenting officer is malwina izziak
when you're ready take it away
thank you chairman
um good evening
um
so we are considering application at 3
15 22 and 23 Bennett Place in ilmington
as you can see the site is
um
in Elmington as denoted by the black dot
on this plan
the application site comprises of four
dwellings within a residential cool de
sac two terrorist bungalows
cladded in stone these are number 22 and
two-story tourist dwelling cloudating
brick number three
and an end of Terrace Bungalow clouded
in Brick
number 15 the locations are shown as
thread outlines on this plan and here
you can see the conservation area and
the listed buildings contained within
um
what is being proposed is to improve the
Energy Efficiency of the four dwellings
namely apply external insulation to
external elevations
and also replace the windows and doors
on this plan you can see
um the two
Bungalows
um on the top you can see the proposed
front elevations and the insulation will
have a finish to match the existing
which is a stone and coins
and in the rear the elevations would be
rendered
number three the two-story detached the
two-story Terrace dwelling sorry and to
the front is going to have brick
cladding finish and in the rear render
and the fourth property number 15 will
have a brick cladding too much the
existing finish
and I'm going to show you
the photos of the dwellings you can see
here
um number 22 and 23.
on this Photograph you can see number
three
and number 15 is at the bottom of
Bennett Place
just there
this is number 15.
and this photo shows the street scene so
the top photograph shows
um the conservation area to the west of
the sides
taken from within Bennett Place
and the bottom photograph shows Bennett
Place taken from within the conservation
area and here you can see the row of
four terrorist properties and where
number three is located and number 15 is
located at the very bottom of the
cul-de-sac and here you can see the two
bungalows
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application for planning
permission subject to the conditions as
detailed within the committee report and
the updates sheet thank you
thank you very much uh we've got uh one
speaker registered for this this item
which is uh councilor Karen peachy from
Elmington Parish Council
good evening councilor
um
so you've got three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning
um it's the button on the right just to
turn the microphone on when it's red
you're good to go and uh take it away
um so good evening again Bennett Place
Wilmington stands within the area of
outstanding natural beauty
dwelling number three is a two-story
house which stands at the center of a
row of three terraced houses
the increase of 100 Mil of insulation
will make it stand proud of its
neighbors on either side
there is also to be an adoption to the
roof Eaves and verges to allow the roof
to adequately overhang the cladding
presumably there will be re-routing of
the guttering
we consider this will be detrimental to
the trip the street scene
dwellings 22 and 23 are the center of a
row of four Terrace Bungalows currently
in line with each other
the proposed installation will make the
two stand proud of the neighboring
properties at either end
and the rendered finish
um on your on the planning statement it
still States
um that off-white render will be used
and yet in the assessment of key issues
it does state that that different
claddings will be used so I'm confused
as to which which will be considered by
your planning committee
um
so if it is the rendered finish it will
it will not be in keeping with the
neighboring properties
um they are also in a prominent and
obvious position as one approaches
Wilmington via Front Street
there was actually no photo of dwelling
15 which is an end Bungalow and I have
to contradict
um the case officer I'm sorry the end
elevation is Brick and the front
elevation is Stone
so to actually the proposed render is
Brick effect to the front and side and
the this will definitely not match the
neighboring bungalows
and it will again bring the frontage to
stand proud of its adjoining property
it's the opinion of elming Parish
Council that the introduction of the
external insulation on all properties
will be detrimental to the street scene
and to the area of outstanding natural
beauty of which Wilmington is very proud
we also believe there are alternative
internal methods which are less visually
intrusive and could be employed to
increase the Energy Efficiency of these
properties
thank you
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our Parish counselor
councilor Parry first
thank you and good evening good evening
um I wonder whether you can advise
within the street scene in Elmington are
all the dwellings where they be detached
or semi-detached is the building line
complete uniformity right across the the
along the street in other words are some
properties a little bit forward or a
little bit back
or are they all exactly within inches
similar building line
I couldn't commit myself to that comment
but the Bungalows at the end stand at an
angle
at the end of the property and they they
are
visible as you approach Wilmington from
the north
and it would be obvious that they're
they're out of line once the once the
cladding's on and I I wouldn't
um I couldn't say that they were all in
line
councilor Harvey next
good evening Council peachy
um
do you know of any other uh properties
within ilmington that have have already
been subject to this change
not to have the the um the cladding
um applied to the frontages no
any other questions from French
counselor in that case uh thank you very
much for your contribution thank you
it doesn't appear that we've got any
other Regis registered speakers in which
case we're moving on to points of
clarification for officer councilor
Pemberton first in
thank you I know condition for
um which does talk about uh samples
being submitted and approved and can I
seek clarification from the officer that
the choice of render and uh will will be
insofar as what's available in the
pallet officers will be seeking to
ensure that it is as sympathetic as
possible with the other properties and
if I could have that clarification
please uh yes so that was the reason to
attach this condition
um
so the developer would submit samples
and which would include the texture the
color the type so we would be in control
of the Finish basically
uh just follow up may I also invite
officers
to if if this committee is minded to
Grant this application could I invite
officers to engage with the parish
council around that process
to ensure I've got as much buying as
possible so um this is this process is
currently in place and if we attach a
material condition which includes
um stone for example use of the stone it
is a standard practice to console the
Parish Council on the discharge of the
condition
customer for clarification we will
decide that this is stone for the
purpose of this application and
therefore we will consult for the
purposes of this application whether or
not it is Stone
thank you counselor Curtis next thank
you no it's fine thank you chair back
councilor Harvey can I ask a question
which you may rule out of order uh
chairman
um It just strikes me that this is not
application in the sense that there's
three four four properties
um is is this part of a continuing
process or is this is this it
Council receives a large number of this
kind this type of applications to
insulate homes especially
um
can I say
leave it to me
I think the answer to your question
counselor is that some properties have
been bought and others remain in the
ownership of orbit so orbit can't uh
Cloud all of the houses in the row they
can only Cloud the ones they own
orbit is the factor
are there any other points of
clarification for officers
no oh Castle passing them
this is obviously very good for the
Energy Efficiency of the house and
um
yes kind of well it's going to improve
the the um
the um fuel poverty situation of the of
the tenants greatly uh presumably
um is there any is part of this
application were there were there any
figures about the Energy Efficiency
improvements of the house
I I'm not
um I do not recall any figures but
um I am aware that
um in line with the assessment of the
principal the developer does not need to
present any evidence
um
to confirm that there is a need to
improve the energy and efficiency
I think
from memory I think I included that in
the principle of development section of
my report
um
oh
so this is paragraph
um 158 of the nppf when determining
planning applications for a renew re
sorry renewable and low carbon
development local planning authorities
should not require applicants to
demonstrate the overall need for
renewable or low carbon energy and
recognize that even small-scale projects
provide a valuable contribution to
cutting greenhouse gas emissions
and approve the applications if its
impacts are or can be made acceptable
any other points of clarification
in which case we can move on to the
debate councilor Pemberton straight in
um
so a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away we had a debate on
declaring a climate change emergency in
this building and some idiot turned
around and told everybody that people
would be dragged Kicking and Screaming
to change and this is one of those
examples
the absolute need to insulate properties
properly balanced against the impact on
a Conservation Area frankly climate
change is an existential threat to the
species there won't be a conservation
area to be enjoyed by any human being if
we don't do something about it so this
is a drag Kicking and Screaming to
change I firmly support officers on this
and vote and I would be proposing grants
and look for a secondary
thank you very much I think I saw
councilor Harvey first but it might be
seconded
thank you very much councilor Parry
just I'm fully in support of it and in
fact orbit have carried out a very
similar exercise
um
in wellesbourne a lot of the orbit
properties have been done exactly like
that the properties look fabulous and
the tenants are a lot warmer and you can
go and have a look it's Elliott Drive
within the portfolio holders Ward which
is
thank you thank you very much uh
councilor Hench Serafin yes I I agree
with counselor and Parry uh in my ward
there are orbit Bungalows and they've
all been externally insulated and they
look absolutely wonderful thank you all
right councilor passing him yeah I was
going to say I've seen quite a lot of
properties like this and the fact that
they stand out proud of the exist the
the adjoining houses
it doesn't seem to you never know I've
never noticed it I've realized they must
be but I've never noticed it and and
just to say I do remember that debate
that cancer Pemberton was talking about
and I remember him saying we've all got
to make very difficult decisions in the
future but I don't think this is one of
them
if you're going to speak please turn on
your microphone first through you chair
I was recognizing merely the challenges
the community face
thank you very much anyone else willing
to speak on this item yeah the the one
thing I would add is my reading of the
report does suggest that quite a lot of
work's been done by the case officer to
try and get as much
um
Conformity to the local Stone and
facades as possible and I think that
seems fairly evident based on what we've
seen tonight so all right
um in that case we have a proposal to
Grant and line of with the officer's
recommendations
[Music]
including the items noted on the updates
sheet uh
which covers an additional condition
okay
very good
um in which case can I see all those in
favor of Grants
really good then in that case this
committee resolves to Grant application
22-03671 ful
now
um that's the last application we move
on to item six urgent business
no urgent business in which case I can
close the meeting thank you very much